obviously a lot of dipsep fans were
disappointed to not see you guys maybe
make an appearance yeah i was
disappointed i wanted to be on the stage
yeah i mean there was a lot of people on
stage you would think like you know what
what what were you like was there any
discussion of that or was that ever
something that was discussed or i was
supposed to make it happen as far as
like uh we were supposed to all yeah be
there you know from my understanding
you know what i mean what do you think
happened
um i don't know
you never know it's like when it kind of
especially when it kind of business like
when money gets involved in certain
things not that i'm saying that that's
that was the cause right but you know i
never got to reach back a quarterback so
i went ahead and um you know
did what we did you know man had an
opportunity with
to walk out uh at the fight with trilla
and she got on my truck so yeah
was there any uh what about with you
well like was there any conversation
with anybody you know about because i
remember watching the battle and you
popping up on the on the screen
like man rail's there why is he not on
stage what the [ __ ] is going on like i
was actually i was like he said he was
ringside so we we just we can't
walk the fight out
and
we was about to leave and i asked jrd
you want to stay for the verse